les r18 ne sont plus en nombre suffisant
pour remplir nos obligations
internationales élémentaire au sein par
exemple de norad ou de l'otan mais c'est
un appareil encore fiable selon le
gouvernement et les experts dans leur
ensemble ne questionne pas ce dernier
point non absolument pas l'aviation du
même jeu tant général rawdon comme deux
semaines devant un comité parlementaire
a mentionné que la flotte de 6,8 et est
parfaitement opérationnel parfaitement
capable de continuer à livrer la
marchandise jusqu'à au moins 2025 alors
c'est quand même lui tendit fille michel
drapeau colonel mettre à la retraite des
forces armées canadiennes avocat et
analyste dans le domaine de la défense
et des affaires militaires croient que
les cf-18 sont toujours des appareils
sécuritaires
même après l'écrasement survenu lundi
près de la base god lake en alberta
niveau de la flotte à ses avions lors
reçoivent de grid perfectionnement au
niveau d'entretien de façon régulière et
puis j'ai aucun de tours fait que
l'avion est en parfaite état parce que
depuis son vol sinon le petit doigt qui
les mécaniciens il est commandant qui
dirige l'opération n'aurait pas perdu
6,8
malgré le fait qu'ils ont un certain âge
oui mais ont subi des modifications des
additions qui rend plus performant avec
deux nouveaux engins et ce genre de
choses là alors c'est quelque chose que
tout le monde pas seulement de
navigation mais touchants et quelle est
sa défense veut s'assurer que nos avions
sont sécuritaires que les pilotes sont
en insécurité vol des avions qui sont
ces actions capables de livrer la
marchandise
hab sujet pas l'ombre d'un doute là
dessus
l'achat de nouveaux chasseurs pour
l'aviation militaire canadienne et dans
les cartes depuis l'élection en 2006 du
gouvernement conservateur de stephen
harper la tension était précisé en 2010
les membres la défense nationale voulait
absolument les 35 donc ils ont ils ont
dans le fond biaiser le processus
d'acquisition pour qu'on achète et 35 en
dépit des coûts et donc le plein
problème alterne qui a forcé le
gouvernement canadien
m dans le fond le tout sur la classe de
jean christophe bouchet et professeur en
sciences politiques
université gradnik humaine en alberta et
là on évalue donc on se retrouve avec
des avions de chasse qui qui ont discuté
volet donc il faut les il faut les
améliorer
l'avion américain f-35 est plombé par
des problèmes techniques mais le cf-18
lui de l'aviation militaire canadienne
est alourdi par le poids des années
en 2025 certains avions auront 45 ans le
ministre de la défense du canada
révélait donc la semaine dernière en
conférence de presse que le gouvernement
fédéral souhaite acheter 18 nouveaux
avions de combat super hornet de boeing
quant à l'appel d'offres pour l'achat du
nouvel avion de chasse du futur du
canada promue par le parti libéral lors
de la donne en campagne électorale
eh bien ce ne sera pas lancé avant que
l'examen de la politique de défense
canadiennes soit terminé il va falloir
donc en principe attendre encore cinq
ans le temps d'une nouvelle élection il
permet un gain de temps pour regarder
afin de choisir vraiment à plate et non
tel mais entre-temps du talion l'heure
je crois qu'il est utile
la médaille la nage pour y regarder on
va déjà voir des faits super hornet
alors pourquoi pas les mains vides dumas
et doctorant à l'école nationale
d'administration publique enap et
qu'elles ont toutes la même pièce que
les contrats de maîtrise ils font une
annonce tardive sans savoir vraiment
combien ça va coûter qu'elle songeait
tomber et quels seront les impacts sur
les opérations
en ce moment on va me suivre davantage
se détachent les conservateurs de
dossiers look très même année avec le
être enfin en formation qui est
d'éduquer contrat de prêt ni coups qui
ont ce qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils en font
le coup de rein est votre version
ils ont dit que la chaîne avions alors
reste à lyon je n'ai pas encore fait au
point
fox aux combes or donc qui est plein de
problèmes si encore prenez ça va
rappeler nos engagements
pas de grand remplacement du cf-18 avant
cinq ans d'ici là ottawa va entreprendre
des négociations avec les états unis et
boeing en vue de l'acquisition de ces 18
super hornet du constructeur américain
l'idée de recourir à des super hornet a
toutefois déjà été rejetée dans le passé
par un groupe d'experts mis sur pied par
le gouvernement au motif que cela serait
trop coûteux on concluait que l'aviation
militaire canadienne se retrouveraient
contrainte de faire voler deux types
d'appareils
ce qui nécessiterait deux types de
programmes de formation de type
d'infrastructure deux types
d'équipements différents un reportage de
radio canada international